I have a rule that especially on Twitter
I do not tweet or talk about the
Kardashians but this story is so idiotic
that I felt it warranted me breaking my
own rule so Kim and Kanye which is Kim
yay or is it it's Kim yay and their and
their child North they have a did they
have a new car and it is a 1 million
dollar bomb and bulletproof vehicle that
is a take off of what President Obama
uses let's let's take a look at this
thing so that is that is what its gonna
look like this thing is literally a
million dollars it has ever it is I mean
some of this stuff is just completely
insane
it has whale penis skin upholstery if it
wasn't clear their whale penis skin
upholstery which is the best yeah I
don't you have that whale penises does
it take to upholster a car does the
whole car with two killer whale penis
you could probably do it also has jewel
encrusted snake or in a man all right so
let's throw up the cartoon of the second
car they're getting which is the actual
mock-up of Obama's car and here you go
there's Obama sitting here he posed for
that actually and he's very you know and
you can see this is not gonna have the
whale skin penis interior yet exactly
but yeah and it's a million dollars it's
gonna withstand bombs and bullets and
all this crazy stuff what is the point
of becoming a celebrity if you have to
have a bomb-proof car house my mind
about this whole thing it's like at
least Kanye West has said some political
things that have gotten some people mad
can you imagine being Kim Kardashian and
saying I don't do anything and that
makes people so mad I think they might
throw bombs at my child right exactly
well there's a ton of hate for the two
of them and I think some of it is
warranted in the way the Kardashians
want the money and have just put this
awful thing on us and you know obviously
Kanye has done a lot of controversial
stuff but like having a drive
and about is or is this that they want
the idea what I was going to say I
personally I would say they and that's
an unfair generalization to include
Kanye in this but he's now affiliated
with Kim so much so that they're just
you know Kimmy a yeah but Kim Kardashian
has made a career of her relevance being
about people talking about her yeah and
you have to stay current well I was
pregnant and then I you know I did okay
I did a sex tape and that made me famous
enough to do a reality show and then I
had to sell off my wedding pictures and
my wedding gun ended my marriage ended
two seconds later and then I oh I need
to get pregnant now so I'm gonna be
affiliated with this guy and know the
baby's here and I'm gonna give you the
ridiculous name so that people are still
talking about me what does she do now
what's next so do you think okay so that
I think is the interesting part is do
you think that they actually sit down
and they're like what can we do now to
get back in oh let's get a bomb-proof
car because those Schmucks at HuffPost
are gonna post it and all these idiots
like me are gonna talk about it is that
is it really that calculated I don't I
think that they said they're going well
what can we do next I don't know that
they actually asked that question but
Kanye probably thinks highly of himself
and you may not want to put him in in in
the category of Kim Kardashian but you
also know that whale penis skin was his
idea
he loves his fabrics but he's sitting
there and he's going you know what we
should get a bomb-proof car yeah he
thinks very highly of himself and Kim's
like yeah that's a great idea and then
her mom comes out like a little gremlin
from around the corner yes yes exactly
and then they that's when they start
thinking of how ridiculous can we make
this car to get it up together you know
we were talking to on the show a couple
weeks ago about how when the Royal baby
was born I was saying how I actually
think that America not that we need a
royal family but I think England gets
something sort of healthy out by having
a royal family that we may we want Obama
to be everything where they get it out a
little bit with the royal family and
then their politicians can actually do
politics are we getting royal family is
like like are we getting some of that
stuff out where we treat people like Kim
and Kanye like the royal family at this
point please God tell me you're not
saying I think Kanye would be
the equivalent of our boy the American
version of it sadly I think okay next
plane to Jamaica and leaving like I'm
out yeah trust me this is not what I
want this is just sort of the state of
America that we have this like
equivalent of the royal family like
these people and not just them this
others at America's accepted it I mean
who's on the cover of all the British
tabloids is the royal family who's on
the cover of all we Americans have boys
it's Kimye yeah you know what I mean and
I mean you're shocked and appalled
is the American royal family anybody
anybody yeah a bunch of drunk alcoholic
murderers like the Kennedys maybe all
right well I promise you I am gonna not
talk about that anymore I broke my own
rule here and well we'll see what
happens